so there's a a designer you mentioned
uh johnny ave
uh you both are brilliant designers
great human beings there were some
battles fought
in you in the distant past between the
two of you
uh looking back what is the positive
characteristics of johnny that made you
a better person and designer
having worked with him
watching the process that the design
team
that johnny led
i don't know where because that was over
years i didn't see all of those things
but watching the design process of
really because it was really
a team that was about materials it was
about form it was about colors it was
about these physical characteristics
it it when we talked about this earlier
was design what is design designs
everywhere okay so what they were really
focused on was form
how the feel was how it looked the
aesthetics the physical aesthetics
and watching going through that process
i learned so much in that process
about how to do colors
how to do materials how to
think
deeply about
curves
right and shadows
and how it would look not just in your
hand but how it would look in the
photograph you were going to take for
marketing
right so how it would look how it would
feel
all of it it was it was all of those
physical things
around that and watching the process to
get there
that was enlightening for me right it
opened my mind to go oh
okay
just like there's a process for all
these other things it wasn't just
magic and you say
ah there it is it was really a process
of refinement you know of opening the
funnel at the beginning and refining
down over time to get to that final
final and selecting and doing the
selection and certain types you could
certain times there were opinion-based
design
details yeah but a lot of data a lot of
data-driven designs of what could we
what can we de deliver in volume what
can we do different things so you always
had these constraints that you had to
work with under and sometimes
they uh and the team not just i would
say we need this we're like we can't
deliver that but maybe we were able to
work together to find different design
characteristics and different
implementation characteristics that
could
get to that point without what they were
describing and instead of
yes yes yes no no no let's find some
other way to solve the problem together
yeah is
and i've seen this um
and several companies have more closely
interacted with like tesla as an example
sometimes you know talking about curves
sometimes it's very painful on the
engineering side
to deliver a very specific kind of
absolute thing and
one question that comes up in my mind is
like well how far should we go to try to
deliver
a tiny adjustment in a curve
in the curvature or in um
like the whatever the form factor is in
the color of the material
when the cost is like 10x to deliver
not financially but just like you know
yeah there's somebody to do it how many
problems still have to solve
um
i don't know i don't know if you can say
any wisdom to that because it because
when you're thinking about curves you're
designing in the space of ideas you're
like platonic forms kind of thing
uh not always grounded to like how much
this is
uh how much pain is going to be involved
in delivering this but that's as you
should perhaps because then
uh if you're always thinking about the
pain required to deliver
this thing you pro you'll be too
conservative you wouldn't do the wild
ideas
right exactly but you have to understand
again the why behind it and at
nest when we had limited resources
you know putting a screwdriver in the
box a custom
designed screwdriver in the box was born
out of those experiences i had at apple
and seeing how you can create something
that's emotional it's part of marketing
and it's part of the product experience
overall even though it it seems
extraneous
i went back and made the design team
and the mechanical team changed some
curves on the nest protect the smoke and
co detector we did at nest
after they had already tooled it and i
said they're saying this cost more i
said it doesn't look right there is a
but they're like oh well we had i said
no you're going to go back and you're
going to make that change i told you you
want we needed to do it we had a better
looking model that is going to get done
i know it's going to be a terrible cost
to you but we already had this
discussion and that's the way it's gonna
have to be and i'm sorry but it is what
it is
um and you know because it's better for
the customer and it looks better and the
pictures and all the other stuff and
then we did it and it was great and
everyone agreed it was great at the end
but it was pain to get there
um
those are where those little details are
where the magic comes out right and
you know
if you don't do
if you don't take those pains and put in
the love the customer's gonna feel
it's gonna they're either gonna feel the
pain or they're gonna feel the love
if you put it in right so it depends on
you know
how much time and effort you wanna put
into something and what really matters
to you and so how you communicate what
you do we're human beings after all is
there
something you've learned from sort of
the
the tensions that are natural
or that happen in teams when they're
passionate and they're trying to solve
these problems is that the way of life
and there's the human drama
is that just
is that always good is that it is what
it is
is that make you better actually the the
drama of the tension between
personalities and all that kind of stuff
look a roller coaster ride without ups
and downs is no fun
it's the journey yeah it's the journey
that brings it brings out the best in
everyone we're we're we're we're we're
forged we're tempered by those
experiences not all the ups but also the
downs and that's when you get the
humanity in the connection and we can
tell these stories till we're blue in
the face and smile every time because we
did something together that we each of
us couldn't do a part but it when you're
comes together that's where all the
emotions happen yeah and that's where if
it's born out of the right reasons and
the right story in the right way that's
where the magic happens not just for the
customer but for how it transforms each
person who is working on it and they
will never forget those experiences in
their life
positively and negatively that happened
at the time but they look back and it's
only positive
because they did something that mattered
you